hi Dan how are you six-five 235 down
from 251 I'm ready to go with you guys
I'm ready
do you want to you want to get there
right now with you against the dance in
a shooting contest you got to beat some
people to get to the champ but yeah I do
I have friends sometimes I can't listen
I generally listen every day but
sometimes I can't yeah and man every
time you mention it I've got all my boys
hit me hard okay great you have to go
through McLovin and seaton to get to me
to get to this you got that wrong you've
got to come up with a champ from the man
cave and I'll be sitting there with my
ball with my woody harrelson hat ready
to go against whoever gets it done out
of you guys that's it if I got my show
against your show five on five well I've
got one producer I would have to go into
the sales staff and find a couple gals
but I can I can do this I can run five
guys together from our station but it
would have to be half court because we
eat a lot around okay all of a sudden
Damon Bailey can't appear on your staff
there you can't be doing any ringers
their regular contributor right you
can't have Reggie Miller out that oh
he's the fifth Danette though no I've
heard and you know what I love is you're
gonna be guarding me I love that
I can't wait let me try so I'm getting
the stance extend my arm fall you man
you're gonna have to back cut to get a
bucket is all I'm saying you're not
getting anything easy like RJ Barrett
last night walk it out that's the boy
ain't half that big date man I already
torched you years ago so nothing's
changed in when we played we played a
pickup game and Dayton and Donny Mae was
there and come on you got the wrong guy
I've never met Donny May I know he is
you were there you were coaching at
Bowling Green I think dad dad Dan I've
never been in a pickup game when I was
coaching at Bowl
in green I haven't been in a pickup game
that wasn't either on Bowling Green this
is sad Indiana University is is sick
people will tell you I have a
photographic memory no you use you were
you used to coach at Bowling Green yeah
and then I thought god this guy used to
be decent at Indiana now look at what
happen I'm torching him I felt bad about
it
I called Bob Knight and I said coach
dockage is not any good
can you bring Calbert Cheaney over coach
I need somebody who can guard me Ricky
Callaway somebody is meth legal in
tonight do you have PTSD from when I
destroyed you I'm not sure which one
called my jumper an IUD I mean come on I
owned you that day but that's okay all
right you know whatever we can revisit
it okay
let's start with Kansas last night
because Kansas number one team in the
country do you think there's still the
number one team in the country no okay
no I thought Kansas was good I thought
Michigan State's gonna get really good
but I know the number one team in the
country is Duke and it's not close but I
think Kansas if you said to me and I
heard you guys earlier and you're so
right
man would that be great if it was Kansas
Duke tonight you know that would be
incredible get or give him a day to
relax and then come back and play it
tomorrow I don't care
Dan being there I thought Kansas was
good I did I thought Kansas the guard
play of Quinton Grimes was absolutely
fantastic and you know you're really not
going to talk about it because you're
going to talk about this freshman from
Duke but he was terrific
the bigs Lawson really good in his debut
I thought Kansas was really good until I
saw Duke and then I thought wait a
second everybody else is not on this
level at least last night and Dan I know
you're a tad delusional right now but
yeah but try to focus here everybody
that watched Duke
I live in the building and probably at
home you could see a stark difference
between between the size the length of
Duke and even Kansas but I do think it
would be a very good game because you
said it's you know somebody's gonna
games are different Duke was throwing
everything in but Kansas is really good
and I looked for Michigan State to get
really good Nick Ward didn't play well
he'll play really well during the year
all right if you look at this the rest
of the year with Duke where do you see
where somebody's going to take advantage
of them or you know at least make them
susceptible yeah I think a couple things
I think you said it earlier you know
maybe it was you maybe there's somebody
else I've been listening I'm driving I'm
doing Cincinnati Ohio State so I'm
driving over to Cincinnati but I think a
couple things III think that you know
hype around Duke is going to get so big
the environments they're gonna play are
going to be crazy like even last year
Virginia Tech was an OK team I did the
game
Virginia Tech beat him at Virginia Tech
I need a couple things I think you got
to keep saying Williamson in front he I
think people will learn that if he's
gonna you know if he's gonna jump up
over you and make shots and good for you
but you can't you can't let him do
whatever he wants to do it in deep the
RJ Barrett kid is a lot like James Hart
Dan I mean he old boy he he he gets into
those gaps and it's uncanny
bilis was saying it last night there's
just there's an uncanny nassif on us so
you've got to be the guy on the right
and the guy on the left have to be in
help early to slow him down a little bit
and you got to make it tough for him to
get the ball but early in the season Dan
let me back up kentucky's really good
right yeah I went to I went to the
Bahamas and did their games against the
foes they played a Serbian team that had
like three guys that were first are
going to be first-round picks and there
was 18 or 17 NBA scouts and Kentucky
beat him 30 like Kentucky's good but
there isn't a soul gonna believe that
because they were then they were the JV
playing against a varsity last night it
was literally that start who do you
think is if you said you could have RJ
Baird's future or zion williamson well
at my age I'm all about that money so I
think Zion Williamson is a brand I think
he's going to become the shack because
he's got a great smile he's got a got a
great energy to him
I'll take Sian Williamson he's got a
cool name yes better who's better who's
gonna be better I think right now
RJ Barrett is better he's big like like
like he's not little yeah now now you
know Zion williamson's massive and he's
strong I worry about a couple things
with Zion Williamson and this is gonna
be interesting you know Charles Barkley
kind of set the tone for being heavy in
college and then it's really slimming
down as he got into the NBA I wonder
because he's got great shoulders I hope
that that's what Zion Williams and ends
up doing because you know you were
talking about tractor-trailer earlier
you know big baby there's been a lot of
guys that come into the league and
things happen and so RJ Barrett is a is
a not a good a great college basketball
score and he's only played one game if I
gave you Duke or the field this moment
I'll take Duke I don't think they're
gonna go undefeated
I think 76 I think Quinn Buckner and the
boys are going to be popping bottles you
know aka mercury Morris and them at some
point but right now I got take Duke I
just and they beat a really good team
and beat him by a thousand last night
how bad do you think they beat Kansas if
they played tonight if they played
tonight I would say you would go down to
a 5-2 you know if I were gonna make a
spread I'd give Duke and I'd give Kansas
four or five I just look last night Jack
white played great O'Connell's making
everything sign williamson's throwing
its shots with his back to the rim you
know I don't think that would happen
tonight and I think people would you
know have a little better feel about how
to play Barrett now let him catch the
ball things like that so I would make
Duke the favorite but I would make him a
huge favorite if they play tonight are
we gonna run into each other at the
Final Four in Minneapolis yeah I hope so
I would like to meet you for the first
time well now this would be the second
time but you like you blocked out the
first that's the only thing you blocked
out was was meeting me I have to sit in
my safe space and and do some thinking
because I've never met Donny Mae I did
know Don danaher I did know Dan hip sure
I do know Dan Hampshire Big D I think
you were sitting on the sidelines open
for winners and we didn't let you play
yeah well who's the winner now Dan who's
the winner now thank you thank you you I
really love you guys Shawn I told Fritzi
I thought that stuff that he did with
his with his kids Bar Mitzvah or Bat
Mitzvah was really really cool but he
didn't ask you to be in the Bar Mitzvah
video did he I might just throw a chair
across the floor or something like that
were you on the team you weren't on that
team where you Big D I was he comes out
I'll tell you quick stories first time
he never he didn't wear a sport coat
okay wait let me set this up for the
audience now so Dan in the mid-eighties
plan for bob knight in indiana and i
believe this was an exhibition game but
oh no it was a big game against Purdue
oh oh okay and at Purdue yeah no at home
okay all right so I didn't set it up
well but that's as good as I can set it
up so Bob Knight is really steamed and
then you pick it up in there well they
just I hope I don't lose you they just
pulled me down to come into the game and
London Bradley made a couple of bad
calls so my man went to his sport coat
is the first time he never wore a sport
coat and ube blob we're running out
there he goes a Danny he's German guy he
goes a dirty coach is going to get
thrown out today as we talking about
because not wearing a sport coat so he
he reads for a sport coat you really
can't see it on the
film he didn't have it to throw so he
threw a charity I swear to God randy
wittman and i one day counted he threw
fifty-two chairs against the wall in
practice one day so when he threw the
chair none of us were surprised and when
a big deal but apparently it became a
big deal you think so you think if he
had his sport coat there to throw he
would have thrown that instead of the
chair thousand percent oh man absolutely
one thought yeah 1,000% it was a hot day
in Bloomington really a warm February
day and he had a golf shirt if he had a
sport coat there have been no chair
1000% I believe that you live to tell
about it and most of the stories you
can't even tell but that's why it'll be
great to see again and have a couple of
beers and then you can open up the
scrapbook for us a great to talk to you
safe travels and we appreciate your time
as always you guys are great thanks guys
it's a Dan dockage ESPN college
basketball analyst for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]